valéry giscard d'estaing dans le
sud-ouest l'esprit de réforme
s'accompagne du respect de l'opposant
sondage remontée spectaculaire de
raymond barre budget 80 et chaque de la
concertation entre le rpr tu es le
premier ministre messieurs bonsoir tout
d'abord dix ans de prison ferme pour
christina prendre apple
l'héritière d'une des plus grosses
fortunes d'allemagne avait été vous le
savez compromise dans une affaire de
drogue à saint tropez
on avait découvert dans sa ville la plus
d'une tonne et demie de haschich est
remonté cette occasion une filière d'une
douzaine de personnes
les autres accusés ont été eux aussi
sévèrement frappé par le tribunal
correctionnel de draguignan pour vous
donner un exemple
les juges ont grand gros multiplier par
deux les sanctions requises par
l'accusation elle-même et christina van
noppen qui étaient prévenus libres à
l'audience a visiblement payé plus que
d'autres pour le symbole qu'elle
représente paul lefèvre lorsqu'elle est
entrée au tribunal de draguignan
christian von opel pensez peut-être
pouvoir en ressortir avec une peine de
prison avec sursis 10 ans de prison
ferme et 50 millions de centimes
d'amendé
en entendant cela précis n'avait d'opel
s'est écroulé lentement les autres
inculpés 16 ans 10 ans 8 ans 6 ans ont
dû attendre d'avoir la traduction en
allemande pour comprendre pourquoi le
silence était fait brusquement dans la
salle à la lecture du jugement jugement
sévère sévère au point de rejoindre les
prévisions sinon les souhaits des
policiers de la brigade des stupéfiants
de marseille ceux qui avaient suivi la
piste et qui expliquent le poids du
jugement des magistrats leur à guignen
en rappelant qu'il s'agissait là de la
plus grosse affaire de drogue saisies en
france
arrêté à l'audience christina von opel a
bénéficié d'une mesure de courtoisie
inhabituel sans doute parce qu'elle est
une femme
le président a fait évacuer la salle
avant de la faire sortir entre deux
policiers qui faisait semblant de
l'accompagner dehors la jeune femme
s'était présentée au début du procès
comme la victime de l'amour qu'elle
portait à michael kharg
l'inculpé numéro un le père de sa fille
condamné lui à 16 ans de réclusion
criminelle
les magistrats
ont retiré du dossier la conviction
qu'elle était sinon le trésorier du
moins l'une des têtes du réseau de
trafiquants de drogue réseau dont on
sait que d'autres relais en suisse et en
allemagne fédérale existe encore et
continuent de fonctionner peut-être
est-elle aussi le prix d'un nom d'une
fortune d'une notoriété qui aux yeux des
magistrats de draguignan lui ont créé
plus de devoirs que de faciliter
l'espion de la reine bien joli type de
romans policiers mais aussi une réalité
qui a durement secoué les anglais ce
matin à leur petit déjeuner le
conseiller personnel d'elizabeth ii en
matière artistique était bel et bien un
espion au service de l'urss et le
premier ministre anglais lui-même où
elle même puisque ces imams satcher
qu'il l'a révélé en pleine chambre des
députés stupeur aux communes maremne
satcher venait donc de désigner le
quatrième homme de la fameuse affaire
philby marine bergès l'homme avait été
pendant 23 ans jusqu'à sa retraite les
dernières conservateur des tableaux du
palais de buckingham
puis conseiller personnel de la reine
une affaire vraiment étonnante que nous
raconte notre correspondant à londres
philippe harrouard ce livre est à
l'origine d'un beau scandale
son auteur andrew boyle révèle à demi
mot ce qui depuis hier a été rendu
public et passionne les anglais cela
commence en 1930 à cambridge quatre amis
de la haute société philby mclean peu
jesse et plainte flirte avec le marxisme
pendant la guerre devenu diplomate est
agent secret il travaille pour moscou le
scandale éclate en 1951 pour mac line
purchase et la bombe philby explose en
1963 lorsque celui ci passe à l'est et
le quatrième homme
eh bien il est devenu seul anthony blunt
conseiller de la reine pour les arts en
1964 il avoue avoir été lui aussi un
espion soviétique mais un marché est
conclu
comme quoi il ne sera pas poursuivi en
échange de ses aveux
évidemment le gouvernement est au
courant ainsi que le secrétaire de la
reine le silence est bien observer
quinze ans après grâce au livre d'andrew
bogues et grâce un journal satirique qui
met en cause
nommément blunt margaret thatcher révèle
hier au parlement toute la sphère
blindes disparaître dans la nature
buckingham palace a non aussitôt que
seul anthony est destituée de son titre
en 1936 j'ai rencontré un homme
l'académicien qui a connu le plein avant
guerre et m'a dit que d'un effort a été
fait en ce temps là à le recruter pour
le servir dieu c'est lui donc il nous a
dit que blow ne faisait partie du groupe
c'est ça et on s'est tu en as mais ce
n'était pas preuve
vous savez après ça j'ai travaillé
beaucoup j'ai visité les états unis j'ai
lu des documents qui a été fair public
document qui en angleterre sera secret
et ensuite j'ai confirmé ce fait des
membres de mon d'intelligence angleterre
mais cela veut dire que en fait ce sont
un peu des services américains des
services secrets qui ont révélé la faire
oui dans le cours de nature pour ainsi
dire comment pendant quinze ans on n'a
pu cacher cette affaire alors que des
gens étaient au courant en angleterre a
rit beaucoup de gens mais vous savez que
en angleterre il y a une attitude qui je
crois bien de la nature anglaise elle
même une obsession avec les secrets
alors la question qui se pose maintenant
puisque vous avez déjà fait des
révélations
y at il d'autres personnalités qui sont
impliqués dans cette affaire y at il
d'autres personnalités qui sont des
espions soviétiques sont environ 30 ou
quoi finalement c'est une bonne
opération pour nam thatcher que d'avoir
révélé elle même publiquement cette
affaire alors que ses prédécesseurs
l'avait gardée secrète
madame thatcher conforte son image de
premier ministre honnête qui dit toute
la vérité
rien que la vérité le voyage maintenant
du président de la république dans le
grand sud-ouest voyage au milieu des
intempéries et pour poursuivre la
comparaison météo avec une alternance
d'applaudissements et sifflets c'était
déjà le cas hier à saint girons et à
fois ce fut le cas aujourd'hui à rodez à
villefranche de rouergue
mais surtout à toulouse où les syndicats
et partis de gauche avaient appelé à
manifester à 13h nous évoquions l'étape
de rodez voici maintenant la deuxième
partie de la journée la plus
significative à villefranche c'est à
dire chez robert fabre et à toulouse 4e
ville de france
nous y rejoignons notre envoyé spécial
jean louis le sel des crispations tous
azimuts de rodez à villefranche de
rouergue de villefranche de rouergue à
toulouse valéry giscard d'estaing a
trouvé sur sa route aujourd'hui que des
élus acceptant de dialoguer avec lui et
sur ce point il faut surtout noter la
manière dont robert fabre s'est adressé
au chef de l'état dans sa mairie de
villefranche
romain de l'aude mais aussi comme lille
s'en convainquent partisane et on
obtient nabeul je crois que mon devoir
de parler avec la plus grande liberté
le dialogue à messieurs mais la
flagornerie du courtisan ni
l'agressivité sectaire de l'opposant
systématique linéairement non monsieur
propre aux idées ni leur alignement
aveugle aux idées des ondes
c'est une position difficile pour nos
opposants que de tenter de nouer un
dialogue constructif
jeannette et expérience dès 1975 et les
renouveler l'eau glacée en acceptant une
mission sur l'emploi dont les
propositions restent encore rôle
essentiel à être prises en compte
ne serait ce qu'au niveau par exemple
des modalités de retrait et légumes usa
vie mais c'est nécessaire dialogue assez
diminué il n'a de sens que si les boues
sur un infléchissement de la politique
du pouvoir en place car la france vous
plaît on ne cherche difficilement une
idée dans l'action
la signification de votre mission
monsieur le député-maire et l'opinion
publique ne sied pas trompé déborde le
contenu de vos propositions et déborde
de même le problème fondamental de
l'emploi elle rejoint une idée neuve une
idée essentielle dans la vie
démocratique française mais dont je ne
me lasserai pas de proclamer la vérité
5 un homme de l'opposition sans rien
renier de ses convictions peut
participer à l'élaboration des grandes
décisions publiques dès lors qu'il
conduit sa réflexion sans préjugés avec
le désir sincère d'apporter des
solutions concrètes aux aspirations des
français
c'est une de mes tâches
en tant que garant de l'unité nationale
de faire en sorte que le moins de
compétences possibles le moins de bonne
volonté possible reste à l'écart des
circuits de la décision publique cela de
part et d'autre existe des efforts d'un
côté la générosité et le réalisme
ces deux qualités monsieur le député
maire qui ne sont pas complémentaires
vous les avez acquises de votre
engagement politique et l'exercice de
vos divers mandats publics
je souhaite qu'elle soit demain celle de
toute une génération d'hommes de progrès
de l'autre côté le respect de l'opposant
et l'authentic volonté de réforme et de
progrès social
ce respect et cette volonté
je fais tout chacun le sait et je
continuerai de tout faire pour qu'ils
dominent la conduite des affaires de la
france
mais si les élus acceptent le dialogue
en revanche dans la rue ce n'est pas la
même des crispations
depuis le début de l'après midi le
centre de toulouse est bloqué par
plusieurs milliers de manifestants entre
dix et vingt mille selon l'origine des
estimations
les élus socialistes et radicaux de
gauche font nous l'avons vu participer
légalement aux différentes étapes de ce
voyage mais tous ont refusé d'être là
demain à mazamet c'est en effet là que
le chef de l'état doit prononcer en fin
de matinée un discours attendu qui
devrait dépasser les frontières du grand
sud ouest le présent république avait dû
prendre connaissance comme tous les
français du sondage françois riffaud qui
lui étaient favorables +2 % d'opinions
positives mais aussi plus 4 % d'opinions
négatives à la mène à 47% de pour la
surprise vient surtout de la cote du
premier ministre qui a fait un bond de
13 points désormais 41% de pour 50 % de
mécontents
dans le même temps on apprenait que le
chef de l'état l'état dresser une lettre
lundi à son premier ministre pour
fixer le programme d'action qu'il entend
voir suivre par le gouvernement pour les
six mois à venir alors traduction
immédiate de la classe politique
raymond barre et remis en selle pour
moins six mois jusqu'aux grandes
vacances dans le copain merci je ne
crois pas qu'il faille tirer tout de
suite cette école c'est une conclusion
pourquoi parce que c'est une méthode de
travail cette façon d'écrire au
président au premier ministre pour lui
fixer le travail que le gouvernement
pour six mois une méthode de travail et
que le président giscard d'estaing avait
mise au point pratiquement dès le début
de son septennat
il ne faut pas croire que c'est une
façon de renouveler le bail du
gouvernement à chaque fois pour une
durée de six mois mais on verra quand
même qu'elles seront achetés oui il est
certainement conforter et ce qu'il ya ce
qui est vrai c'est que depuis quelques
temps dans le climat politique
on sent très nettement que tout le monde
pense que le premier ministre monsieur
raymond barre restera premier ministre
encore assez longtemps et les sondages
vous pariez tout de suite ne font encore
que renforcer ce clip we des sondages
l'assemblage corporelle par celui de la
sofres réalisé pour de faire des
journaux de province et qui dit que 58%
des français estiment que vraiment batam
bon premier ministre contre 30% qui
estiment le contraire mais là on
s'interroge depuis qu'on a eues ces
sondages sur les raisons qui expliquent
et cette remontée spectaculaire du
premier ministre alors je crois qu'il ya
déjà un certain nombre de raisons assez
personnel par exemple vit dans une
réaction de sympathie après
l'hospitalisation du premier ministre
également le fait que monsieur raymond
barre a toujours su garder une image
d'homme qui se situer en dehors de la
classe politique et qu'il ya des raisons
plus politiques
l'inquiétude qui est à la fois
nationales internationales fait
peut-être que les français ont tendance
à se regrouper derrière ceux qui les
dirigent
et puis surtout il ya le fait que les
français d'après le sondage de la sofres
ne vois pas qui pourrait remplacer
monsieur bart et faire mieux que lui
il c'est vrai du côté de la majorité ou
celui qui vient en tête comme concurrent
en tout cas comme successeur éventuel
serait monsieur chaban delmas avec 14%
et dans l'opposition c'est michel rocard
qui se détachent nettement mais
seulement avec 27% mais pour entendre
les français veulent aussi des
éclaircissements sur les différentes
d'affaires du mois c'est à dire les
diamants de bokassa le suicide de robert
boulin ça oui c'est ça notre sondage qui
est soeur a diffusé par et demain par
l'express un sondage de l'institut louis
harris il ressort que les français ont
pris au sérieux les différentes affaires
par exemple 74 2 % d'entre eux estiment
que la ferme
l'un est une affaire grave 50 % estiment
que le gouvernement tout entier est
affecté par ces différentes affaires
53% cependant ici google président de la
république est peu affaibli ou n'est pas
affaiblie du tout par l'affairé des
diamants messi qui ressort le plus de ce
sondage louis harris l'express c'est le
besoin d'être informés et à 64% et les
personnes interrogées estiment que les
journaux c'est dans le rôle de journaux
de publier des documents mettant en
cause des gouvernants et puis surtout 74
74 % souhaitent que le président de la
république s'explique complètement à la
télévision sur l'ensemble de ces
différentes affaires
et vous savez la prochaine émission du
président de la république se fera sur
antenne 2 et d'ici la fin du mois donc
tu devrait satisfaire au moins trois
quarts des français
camille laurens est mort depuis plus de
15 ans était le secrétaire général du
centre national des indépendants et
paysans
il fut ministre de l'agriculture il est
mort hier soir à paris il avait 73 ans
la constatation du rpr avec le
gouvernement a échoué c'est claude labbé
qui viennent le dire il y à quelques
minutes en rendant publique la
correspondance qu'il a échangés avec
raymond barre aujourd'hui à propos des
économies budgétaires nous l'écoutons du
servette table parce que c'est de cette
manière que finalement la concertation
avec une majorité ne donnent pas les
résultats que l'on souhaite ce qui est
une chose mais après dire pas très grave
mais surtout c'est que dans l'intérêt
des français il n'y aura pas ses
économies sur le train de vie de l'état
que nous réclamions avec insistance et
qui sont très importantes
je suis le but on a tout de même
l'impression que le groupe rpr et donc
son président souhaitait et le sabric
est plutôt derrière l'article 49 de la
constitution c'est-à-dire l'engagement
de responsables du tome laisse tout à
fait
la responsabilité de cette réflexion
s'il en était ainsi vous savez il
n'était pas nécessaire pour nous du tout
de rencontrer monsieur bah comme nous
l'avons fait hier il n'était pas
nécessaire de poursuivre la concertation
et si nous l'avions souhaité nous
pouvons très bien rompre depuis très
longtemps
simplement d'ailleurs en montrant une
certaine négligence dans la concertation
sans plus alors vraiment les efforts que
nous avons faits démontrent au contraire
que tel n'était pas notre intention
le lycopène est resté avec nous pour
commenter cette rupture rtr gouvernement
la réponse de vraiment barre mais où
c'est d'abord la demande donc du rpr
c'était deux milliards d'économies et le
rpr souhaitait que le gouvernement
prenne ces mesures par ordonnance après
avoir eu l'autorisation du parlement ils
demandaient aussi la réunion d'une
commission sous l'autorité du ministre
du budget pour étudier ces économies
alors la réponse de raymond barre c'est
d'accord pour une commission mais à
condition qu'on ne fixe pas d' avance le
montant des économies à réaliser
et puis pas d'accord sur la procédure
des ordonnances car dit-il cette
procédure n'est pas approprié le
gouvernement peut procéder de façon
réglementaire c'est à dire par décret
pour réaliser ces économies qui sont
souhaite autre débat qui devrait être
délicat celui sur l'interruption de
grossesse la veille d'une manifestation
du mouvement des jeunes catholiques de
france et de plusieurs organisations
hostiles ou renouvellement de la loi
veil
la commission des affaires sociales a
adopté une série d'amendements pour une
application plus libérale de la loi par
exemple elle substitue à la notion de
situations de détresse elle d'état de
nécessité
elle propose que les hôpitaux publics
soient obligés de mettre à la
disposition des médecins qui pratiquent
l'avortement les moyens nécessaires à sa
réalisation
et qu'en tout cas à l'échelle de service
ne puisse pas s'opposer aux désirs des
médecins volonté sociale
en attendant des développements chez
alstom atlantique où la situation reste
bien figé parle en ce soir de deux
conflits qui touchent les transports
tout d'abord la grève des bus et du
métro à lyon un dépôt d'autobus occupés
par les grévistes a été évacué ce matin
par la police
quant au métro il est toujours
totalement paralysé la grève dure
maintenant depuis plus d'une semaine et
dominique torrès et l enquêté sur place
de mémoire de lyonnais on avait vu de
tel embouteillage
cela fait dix jours que la grève des
1700 receveur de la compagnie des
transports lyonnais a littéralement
paralysé la circulation
pas de métro pas trop liebus 13 plus
d'autobus
la grève qui a débuté le 6 novembre et
qui paraissait en quelque sorte
plastique avec des revendications
portant notamment sur l'augmentation des
salaires la semaine des 35 heures et
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
s'est brusquement durci une semaine plus
tard avec l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre
nous avons organisé un vote qui tout à
fait organiser des mac démocratiquement
qui a donné 60 % pour la poursuite de
l'action
c'était donc un résultat indiscutable
qui n'a pas été apprécié par les actions
d'entreprises lapointe c'est que dès le
lendemain elle faisait occupé dépôts par
les forces de police
par contre ça a été disons une réaction
immédiate du personnel qui dans ces
conditions poursuit la grève encore plus
durement
oui nous avons demandé au directeur de
tcl
pourquoi il a fait appel à la police à
la suite d'un bogue pourtant organisé
conjointement par la direction et les
syndicats qui ne dépend pas de moi
puisque c'est les pouvoirs publics qui
sont lancés forces de l'ordre
l'a7 à puce et les pouvoirs publics se
sont aperçus que la liberté du travail
n'étaient plus respectées comme nous
avions les agents qui voulaient
travailler six agents ne pouvait pas le
faire
ils ont donc décidé de se libérer des
portes des dépôts que les autobus
puissent sortir
c'est ce n'est pas à expliquer notre
grève grève grève constitution bien
entendu mairie travaille aussi toutes
les démarches auprès des préfectures du
maire de lyon tout aussi les général et
bien la démonstration de la forte dès
lors de l'essai locales de négocier
nous craignons une intervention de
l'armée et nous craignons un
pourrissement du conflit
aujourd'hui 125 autobus fonctionne sur
800 c'est peu certes mais les usagers ne
s'en prennent pas vraiment aux grévistes
gêné par la grève oui un peu comme tous
les usagers de deuil en chauffe mais
sans que les les conducteurs de bus
aurait dû adapter un transport gratuit
ça serait plutôt gêné la compagnie que
tous les lyonnais qui s'appuie lancar
avait vaincu font grève ils sont les
affaires
il s'appelle samuel jetez pas les permis
commission je dois aller à la sécurité
je peux pas y aller
pour l'instant la situation est au point
mort
chaque partie en présence forme de
concession d'une concession de l'autre
un histoire peut-être monsieur collomb
le maire de lyon qui vient de proposer
ses bons offices
les contrôleurs du ciel maintenant
conflit au point mort 240 mouvements
d'avions annulé par exemple aujourd'hui
à orly deux avions quand même pu pendant
les horaires de grève décollé à vue
c'est à dire sans l'assistance des
aiguilleurs du ciel canton négociations
elles sont toujours bloqués et 150
contrôleurs ont manifesté ce matin
devant le ministère des transports une
grève qui dure maintenant depuis 19
jours et qui a des répercussions
économiques non négligeables surtout
nous allons le voir pour les petites
compagnies en effet parmi les compagnies
aériennes se sont surtout les petites
compagnies dites de troisième niveau ou
régionales qui sont les plus touchées
par le mouvement de grève des
aiguilleurs du ciel
certaines compagnies funès et déjà des
difficultés financières importantes
de plus elles ne sont pas équipés de
moyens d'atterrissage tout temps et pour
elle les mois d'hiver sont les moins
bons
la tour nerfs transports a mis tout son
personnel en chômage technique depuis le
13 novembre 0 heure mais elle envisage
de reprendre six lignes régulières au
départ de paris dès lundi prochain avec
des horaires décalés les autres petites
compagnies essaye d'assurer au maximum
leur vol et n'ont pour l'instant pas mis
leur personnel en chômage technique
il rappelle rapidement les compagnies
régionales en vécu trois ans difficile
et elles ont fait des efforts
considérables pour parvenir à
l'équilibré pour parler des râles nous
sommes ce trimestre
normalement être équilibrée et ce
conflit qui dure depuis plusieurs
semaines nous amène principalement
supprimer la moitié de nos vols effects
dans les vols qui demeure la clientèle
pour la moitié
où les vols alors en aviation les frais
fixes on représente à peu près 85 % des
frais puisque quand on ne vole pas
seules les consommations d'essence les
frais qui touche et elles sont pas
dépensés donc tous veulent supprimer
provoque des pertes pour me virer
par exemple dans notre cas à ce jour
nous avons subi des pertes de l'ordre de
riom et si fed vont continuer nous
chiffrons que sur un autochtone nous
enregistrons une perte de l'ordre de 2
millions et si le conflit se durcit est
ce que vous envisagez lui mise au
chômage technique
sicaud alors nous l'avions envisagé nous
l'avons repoussé de quelques jours
souhaitant que des mesures
d'amélioration se présente mais s'il ne
faut nous le ferons en sachant tout ce
que ça se présentait nous serons amenés
là dire prendre un pétillant voir si
nous mettons notre personnel en chômage
technique ou bien si nous continuerons à
maintenir nos vols
pour les compagnies nationales et
internationales le problème est
différent air france maintient ses vols
long-courriers après parfois du retard
ou de l'avant sur les horaires selon les
cas mais le manque à gagner chiffré par
la compagnie depuis le début du conflit
et de 50 millions de francs soit le
quart des bénéfices dès l'année dernière
ou si vous voulez l'équivalent du prix
d'un boeing 737 air inter quant à elle
évalue ses pertes à 35 millions de
francs aujourd'hui soit le quart d'un
prix d'un du prix d'un airbus
ces deux compagnies font voler le
maximum d'avions et n'envisage pas pour
l'instant la mise en chômage technique
de leur personnel pour les aéroports
qu'il soit provinciaux parisien la perte
enregistrée depuis 19 jours est
également importante
plus de 10 millions de francs pour les
aéroports parisiens par exemple ils
perçoivent en effet beaucoup moins de
redevances payées habituellement par les
avions qui atterrissent ou décollent et
par les commerces qui aujourd'hui font
moins d'affaires à l'intérieur des
aéroports
mais le malheur des uns fait parfois le
bonheur des autres c'est le cas pour la
sncf qui voit son trafic augmenter très
sérieusement les mesures de prévention
ont été prises tous les trans europe
express ont été renforcées au maximum
il en est de même pour les trains de
nuit en direction du sud et du sud est
enfin les trains du matin et de fin
d'après midi ont été attribués du
maximum de wagons de 1ère classe
quatrième jour de conflit à nice matin
entre direction et syndicat du livre le
journal n'a pas paru ce matin
enfin chez dussollier reprise du travail
à l'assemblée nationale discussions
aujourd'hui du budget de la justice
alain peyrefitte le garde des sceaux en
a profité pour confirmer qu'il y aura
bientôt un débat sur les chaînes des
paies l'échelle dès peines est à dire
une façon comme une autre belle brême
d'aborder par un billet le dossier la
peine de mort daniel dont vous voir ne
vous entend pas bon écoutez c'est
dommage je crois que vous pouviez donc
effectivement confirmé ce que je vivais
à savoir que avant la fin de l'année
alain peyrefitte déposerait donc un
débat un projet de loi en tout cas sur
l'échelle des peines donc une manière
comme une autre d'aborder la peine de
mort la peine de mort un sujet qui
trouve son prolongement dans la sphère
du pull over rouge nous vous en avons
déjà parlé
le film de michel drach retrace
l'affairé ranucci c'est-à-dire
l'assassinât d'une fillette dans des
conditions odieuse et l'exécution de
christian ranucci je vous dis je vous ai
déjà dit qu'à la demande des parents de
la fillette trois minutes de ce film
avait été supprimée et que plusieurs
villes de provence l'interdisait
purement et simplement dans leur salle
hier dans quatre salles parisiennes
la séance a été interrompue par des
bombes fumigènes leurs organes dans
cette affaire deux aspects au fond c'est
vrai quand on fait un film sur une
affaire récente criminels ou politique
il est vrai que ça peut faire du tort à
une famille un particulier à une
collectivité c'est tout à fait exact
et alors c'est à la justice à la demande
de cette famille
ce particulier de cette collectivité
c'est à la justice de trancher
c'est ce qu'elle a fait dans le cas du
film pu lever rouge en supprimant quatre
minutes qui choquait la famille de la
victime est un tueur allemand alors il
faut respecter la décision de justice
mais le problème est de savoir si ces
mêmes particulier où ces familles où ces
collectivités ou des associations des
groupes d'intérêts peuvent eux faire une
certaine manière la justice en décidant
par des pressions ou par la violence
en décidant d'empêcher la projection
d'un film qu'il est mécontente qui les
choquent ou qui les indigne et qui les
indigne peut-être même légitimement
alors d'autant plus que c'est pas la
première fois que ça arrive regarder
avant la guerre il y avait un film très
beau film de vidéos qui s'appelait zéro
de conduite
eh bien il a été mis à la trappe parce
qu'il choqué profondément le corps
enseignant il va tenter à son prestige
il ya eu un film le blé en herbe de
rotor la race était d'après et colette
il a été interdit la projection dans
plusieurs villes à la demande des
associations familiales
il y a eu un film s'appelait le sentier
de la gloire de cendres et kubrick très
très beau sur la période 1917 pendant 20
ans n'a pas pu le projeter la demande
des anciens combattants les liaisons
dangereuses avec gérard philipe a été
interdite dans 70 villes parce que ça
risquait de provoquer des troubles
les bérets verts alors là les bérets
verts on n'a pas pu le projet de le
projeter dans des banlieues de gauche
communistes parce qu'il faisait
l'apologie des américains au vietnam man
de john wayne john wayne la bataille
d'alger
ça c'était parce que sam est contente
elle est partie dans jerry française ya
eu des menaces des bons on n'a pas plus
de projeter récemment chantons sous
l'occupation de la libye et menacent de
bonbons la retirer de la fiche parce que
ça mettait en cause de l'attitude de
certaines personnes sous l'occupation
alors effectivement ça pose un problème
moi ya beaucoup de films qui me
m'indigne contre joue actuellement à
paris j'aurais pas l'idée d'aller
empêcher la projection le problème est
de savoir si les spectateurs sont des
gens adultes justice toujours lourdes
peines requises contre les trois
policiers qui avaient agressé une
octogénaire l'avocat général a demandé
des peines de 15 à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle
les faits remontent il y a deux ans
c'était une affaire dont nous avions
déjà parlé à l'époque en régaler avait
rendu visite à la vieille dame
et c'est là que madame pipi 89 ans avait
appris par sa fille que c'était des
vrais policiers qu'il avait dépouillé de
douze mille francs et de ses bijoux
écoutez ce que fut alors leur dialogue
écouter
mais moi j'ai crié alors ils n'ont mis
une serviette dans l'accueil avait l'ua
drogue
ils m'ont en effet comme toujours la
figure et ils ont dit que je dormais
quand il était venu c'était qui m'ont
foutu la dent musulmans c'est vrai que
là je me nomme et je savais qu'elle
avait près de 90 ans
alors vous vous rendez compte chalon je
me demande c'est copé la police est bien
en mange justement ce tu ne devineras
jamais quitte à cambrioler la dernière
fois qu'ils se sentent trois policiers
du commissariat d'athis ils sont arrêtés
ce sont les policiers qui m'ont parfois
yonnais non nous ne sommes parvenus
et honte oui des lettres piégées dans
des perceptions parisienne dans celle de
banlieue 15 incendies dus à des lettres
qui s'enflamme au moment de leur
ouverture incendie également dans des
boîtes à lettres et ce au moment de
l'échéance du paiement des impôts locaux
ce qui va poser des problèmes bien sûr à
l'administration lire en maintenant
toujours la guerre des nerfs dans une
interview accordée au monde monsieur
banny sable le chef de la diplomatie
iranienne déclaré cet après midi que
l'iran allait refuser de recevoir des
dollars en paiements de son pétrole
réaction des bourses mondiales
fléchissement du dollar mais quelques
minutes plus tard il remontait à la
suite d'un démentis iraniens
tout cela n'est pas facilitée vous le
pensez bien par l'annulation de tous les
rendez-vous de l'imam khomeiny pour des
raisons de santé
jusqu'au 5 décembre à téhéran cinq cent
mille personnes sont venus aujourd'hui
apporter leur soutien aux étudiants qui
occupent l'ambassade des états unis
elles étaient venues écouter le dernier
message de l'imam khomeiny il aurait été
transmis à la yaute la montée stary mais
vous allez le voir sur ces images
la présence de l'ancien premier ministre
mais déjà d'argan a été aussi fortement
remarquée j'ajoute à cela des
manifestations également en france à
nice tout d'abord où les étudiants
iraniens ont occupé la faculté de
lettres et à paris d'autres étudiants
iraniens occupe en ce moment l'ambassade
dire les sports maintenance demain en
football bien sûr france tchécoslovaquie
match retransmis par antenne 2 pour ce
match au parc des princes michel hidalgo
a choisi des joueurs très athlétiques et
excellent technicien l'étude sovac son
tenant du titre ils sont pratiquement
qualifiés pour la phase finale des
championnats d'europe
même battus par la france il ne
risquerait pas d'être éliminés ou
simplement en cas de défaite ou de match
nul face aux luxembourgeois en
tchécoslovaquie ce qui constituerait
bien sûr une grosse surprise
souvenez vous du match aller le 4 avril
quelques soirées qui bat france 2 à 0
premier but
vous allez le voir un penalty à la suite
de cette action effectivement très
litigieuse penalty donc transformé par
les tchécoslovaques facilement et le
deuxième but que vous allez voir
maintenant toujours le 4 avril à prague
est le deuxième but et réussi par stam
basher à la suite de l'action qui se
développe en ce moment sur votre écran
très beau but de loin à bratislava et
non pas à prague pardon
et demain sur antenne 2 dont le match
retour au parc des princes la météo
maintenant avec un spécialiste vrai de
vrai qui avait laissé sa place hier à
notre robot qui se croient d'ailleurs
bien qui n'a pas bien prévu ce qu'il
fallait en tout cas qu'est-ce que vous
ne prévoyez vous pour samedi et pour
dimanche moins formel j'essaie d'être un
peu plus chaleureux que lui mais mes
nouvelles sont tout aussi fraîche
température aujourd'hui était de 4
degrés cet après midi dans le nord à 10
degrés dans le sud est comme leur froid
humide continuera à couler sur le pays
eh bien il fera encore froid demain avec
même des risques de gelées le matin du
brouillard et donc sans doute du verglas
sur les routes principalement dans le
bassin parisien le centre le massif
central également dans tout le nord-est
du pays dans la journée bien du soleil
c'est vrai mais également des passages
nuageux avec quelques averses de pluie
de grésil et même de neige en montagne
en particulier mais moins nombreuses
tout de même qu'aujourd'hui et
principalement localisées dans l'est du
pays l'après midi
et puis en fin de journée changement de
tableau en effet des nuages arriveront
sur la bretagne dans l'après midi
accompagné suivie de pluie en début de
soirée ça signifie que dimanche cette
ligne depuis traversera le pays du
nord-est vers l'est sud est
alors bien sûr de la pluie ça signifie
un radoucissement il y aura tout de même
de la neige en montagne est un petit peu
en plein à l'avant des pluies mais ce
radoucissement va quand même nous gâcher
un petit peu une partie de la journée du
dimanche coller tout ça n'est pas très
sympathique les prochains rendez vous
avant de nous quitter
avec la formation d'antenne 2 tout
d'abord ce soir à 22h45 le dernier
journal de pierre-alain demain samedi
ennemis présentée par jean-claude mains
jouées georges bégoux sera consacré à la
chanson française avec comme invité
cerrone adamo est également henry
chapier le journaliste ans henry chapier
qui vient d'être nommé par jean philippe
lecat monsieur chance je vous fais part
également du report de cartes sur tables
prévues avec kiel yasser arafat pour
lundi prochain le leader olp doit
participer au sommet arabe de tunis
alors lundi soir nos caméras seront en
israël à l'occasion du deuxième
anniversaire du voyage historique du
président sadate
au cours de cette émission vous pourrez
entendre une interview du général
paceman milices de défense
une interview réalisée par jean pierre
elkabbach paul nahon et jacques à bouche
voilà je pense que je vous ai tout dit
je vous retrouverai avec plaisir lundi
et je vous souhaite de passer une bonne
semaine en compagnie de léon zitrone à
20h bonsoir à tous